en la mayoría de los libros de física
les dicen que la gravedad es
estoy en 9.81 metros sobre segundo al
cuadrado en la superficie de la tierra
aunque es una aproximación lo que quiero
hacer aquí es calcular el valor cuando
usamos la ley de la gravitación
universal la ley de la gravitación
universal
nos dice que la magnitud de la fuerza de
gravedad
va a ser igual
a
una constante
gravitacional que
está bueno de hecho la voy a poner el
mismo color
es la constante de gravitacional g
por la multiplicación
de las masas de los objetos m 1 por m2 y
esto dividido entre la distancia que
separa el centro de ambas masas al
cuadrado le vamos a llamar r al cuadrado
entonces la magnitud de la atracción
gravitatoria entre los objetos como les
digo es esta constante gravitatoria que
es este valor 6.67 35 por 10 en al menos
11 metros cúbicos cúbicos sobre
kilogramo por segundo al cuadrado
bueno conocemos la masa de la tierra que
es 5.97 22 por 10 a la 24 kilogramos
y bueno cómo va a ser la masa de la
tierra pues va a ser una de estas masas
la otra masa va a ser de alguien o de
algún elemento que se encuentre aquí
sobre la superficie la distancia del
centro de la tierra hasta la superficie
es de 6 mil 371 km
entonces bueno aquí tenemos todos los
datos y vamos a asumir que la distancia
del centro de la tierra y la superficie
es este radio si queremos conocer la
magnitud de la aceleración que por
cierto aquí escribí solo la magnitud
pues no he indicado la dirección en ésta
la magnitud de la aceleración es tenemos
que es igual la fuerza el vector fuerza
es igual a la masa por la aceleración al
vector aceleración aquí no he indicado
la dirección pero es un vector si
queremos saber la aceleración vamos a
despejar este mismo forma que nos queda
que aceleración es igual a la fuerza
entre la masa
y si queremos saber la magnitud porque
bueno no estamos indicando la dirección
es igual a la magnitud de la fuerza de
gravedad o de la fuerza de tracción
entre la masa
para encontrar la aceleración debido a
la gravedad que conocemos este valor
pero ahora queremos calcularlo usando
estas fórmulas
pues tenemos que dividir esta fórmula de
la fuerza debido a la gravedad
entre la masa
así que nos va a quedar voy a escribirlo
aquí abajo la magnitud
de la aceleración debido a la gravedad
va a ser igual a la fuerza de gravedad
de la tierra
entre la masa
de la tierra bueno en este caso vamos a
usas
una de estas mcm uno va a ser la masa de
la tierra y la otra es m2 la masa de lo
que queremos usar entonces vamos a
dividir esto entre m2
así que sustituimos esta fórmula aquí y
nos queda que la aceleración
va a ser igual a esta fórmula que es g
por mt
la masa de la tierra por m2
/
el radio
y todo esto dividido
entre m2
m2
estos elementos se eliminan y nos queda
que usando la ley de la gravitación
universal la aceleración de la gravedad
es va a ser igual a esta constante g
por la masa de la tierra
/
el radio al cuadrado que ellos han
estado olvidando el radio o la distancia
al cuadrado
a veces esto se conoce como el campo
gravitatorio de la superficie terrestre
y bueno vamos a calcular esto y después
lo compararemos con este valor que sea
que está en los libros de texto y
finalmente veremos cómo cambia este
valor conforme nos alejamos de la
superficie terrestre en particular a la
altura donde se encuentra la estación
espacial internacional
que bueno la estación espacial
internacional se encuentra más o menos
así por acá a este punto
400 kilómetros por encima de la
superficie terrestre
que comparados con los seis mil 371
kilómetros pues no es demasiado pero
bueno si influye en los cálculos
ok entonces haciendo los cálculos y esto
se los dejo para que ustedes los hagan
comprobaremos que si resolvemos esto
estos valores es decir sustituimos en
esta fórmula
de la aceleración
es esta cantidad
6.673 5 por 10 a la menos 11
como multiplicado bueno de hecho ponemos
las unidades metros cúbicos sobre
kilogramos por segundo al cuadrado y
esto lo multiplicamos por la masa
terrestre que es
5.972 2 por 10 a la 24 kilogramos
y lo dividimos entre el cuadrado
de
6.371
al cuadrado y quedan aquí son kilómetros
cuadrados
cuanto nos quedaría
si resolvemos todo esto y de hecho bueno
estos kilómetros tendríamos que pasar a
metros para que nos queden las unidades
si ustedes resuelven esto en la
calculadora nos va a quedar una cantidad
que va a ser igual a
9.80 y
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado aquí
estos kilómetros al cuadrado lo tenemos
que transformar junto con esto a metros
cuadrados entonces los metros cuadrados
se cancelan con los metros cúbicos nada
más nos queda aquí uno metros encima
estos kilogramos se anulan con los
kilogramos de acá y nos queda segundo al
cuadrado así que las unidades
nos quedan adecuadas nada más es que
hagan el cálculo correspondiente y
verifiquen que esta es la cantidad que
da
si lo redondeamos nos queda
9.82 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
y ustedes pueden bueno preguntarse pues
qué pasó aquí porque es diferente este
valor
con respecto a este valor
bueno la discrepancia se debe a que la
tierra no es una esfera uniforme ni de
densidad uniforme que es lo que asumimos
al usar esta fórmula la tierra en
realidad está un poco aplanada en los
polos y definitivamente no tiene una
densidad de uniforme es decir no todo el
material que del que está compuesta está
distribuido uniformemente en ella hay
partes que son más densas o que tienen
más cantidad de material y otras que no
tienen tanto material entonces por eso
es que se dice así tiene esta
discrepancia esta diferencia de valor
si tienen todo tipo de detalles e
interacciones y si vemos la medición de
la gravedad efectiva se va a encontrar
un efecto de rebote por parte del aire
que aunque es despreciable pues no sé si
hubiera sido suficiente para afectar
esto pero además otros efectos menores e
irregularidades y esto ocasiona esta
diferencia entre estas cantidades
haciendo a un lado esto tengo curiosidad
de cuál será la aceleración de la
gravedad si no se le lleváramos 400
kilómetros como les digo aquí que
tenemos en estación espacial
internacional que está aquí a 400
kilómetros por encima de la superficie
como variaría la aceleración
gravitatoria al respecto en este caso
bueno todos los datos serían los mismos
sólo que
en este caso vamos a reescribir lo
6.673 5 que es nueva constante
gravitatoria voy a omitir unidades para
hacer que me quede el espacio para
escribir las cantidades
aquí sería por 5.9 7 22 por 10 a la 24
pero ahora la división o el cuadrado o
el cuadrado del radio en lugar de ser 44
mil 371 kilómetros a esto le agregamos
400 kilómetros que es donde está la
estación espacial internacional
y nos quedan unos 74 56 76 mil 771
kilómetros como r así que esta cantidad
es 6 mil
771 kilómetros al cuadrado ahora con
este cambio qué cantidad nos queda como
la aceleración de la gravedad
así que de nuevo les dejo que ustedes
hagan los cálculos
y
nos va a quedar que la esta nueva
aceleración en la estación espacial
la aceleración de la gravedad le voy a
poner international space station
va a ser igual a
8.69 metros sobre segundo al cuadrado
esta es la aceleración de la gravedad
que tienen los astronautas y las
personas que se encuentran aquí y es
humano muchos de ustedes podrían pensar
que el estar aquí en dando habitación la
estación espacial están ya no tienen
gravedad y no es cierto si hay gravedad
aquí si hay una aceleración gravitatoria
pero como se está moviendo en la
estación espacial internacional en
órbita digamos que está cayendo
constantemente hacia la tierra pero
nunca la alcanza los invito a que
revisen las unidades que son correctas
al hacer estas operaciones entonces aquí
debemos darnos cuenta de algo importante
bueno como les decía que hay gravedad al
estar en órbita la única razón por la
que se siente o parece que no tienen
gravedad es porque es estación espacial
se está moviendo tan rápido
que jamás alcance la tierra en el
siguiente veremos vídeo veremos qué tan
rápido se tiene que mover la estación
para mantenerse en órbita y evitar
desplomarse la tierra por la acción de
la gravedad